c'est la seule question c'est pas
glorieux
[Musique]
on n'arrive pas à voir le avoir le lien
entre les gouttes
[Musique]
tout à fait je suis totalement toujours
féministe en 2001 même si je suis si
j'observe et je pense que ça serait
quelque chose à célébrer en tout cas en
france dans les pays occidentaux il ne
reste plus beaucoup de choses à gagner
en fait
ba est ce qu'il faut j'ai envie de dire
je lui souhaite bien du courage
[Rires]
que savait que ça allait être possible
en jugement de valeur mais je pense que
voilà ça fait partie de cette partie des
féministes
ils sont très très culturaliste très
utopique c'est qu'ils ne voient pas
comme on y ressent un peu hors sol par
rapport aux réalités des choses et en
finir avec les hommes malheureusement ou
heureusement ou de manière très très
neutre je pense et sans beaucoup trompé
je crois qu'il y à beaucoup de femmes
qui ne sonne ne paraît pas
[Musique]
elles sont différentes des autres dans
le sens où ce sont des femmes trans moi
je comprends pas quand mayer en ayant en
tout cas un peu de recul sur les travaux
scientifiques sur les trans on voit on
voit quand on voit quand même une espèce
de mutation très nette des dernières
années deux camps mounir de justement
vouloir encore une fois c'est pas du
tout où les 30 c 'est une minorité c'est
une minorité très très militante
et justement si une minorité qui
voudraient faire croire qu'ils le
croient qu'ils le croient elle-même et
eux-mêmes que il ya aucune différence
entre les personnes bio et pas en france
si en fait qu'à une différence mais
c'est pas grave c'est pas parce qu'il ya
une différence que il faut que ça
justifie
ils ont moins de droits etc ces
polémiques cesser ces polémiques manager
je les comprends vraiment pas et je
comprends pas la violence quelle qu'elle
suscite parce que pour moi c'est assez
évident et cgc je pense évident pour
beaucoup de gens que les personnes trans
ne sont pas voilà où on est différence
avec les personnes bio au 6 mai c'est
pas grave en fait
[Musique]
c'est pas la question à la question
paraît il a eu la question ne se pose
pas vu que des hommes mais comme bien
les humains et les humains les humains
sont des singes mais le fait est que oui
je suis je suis très très passionnée par
les études sur les primates non humains
justement parce que ça permet de voir
tous les voilà tous tous les points
communs et toutes les différences en
avait que est justement de communiants
de de sentir de manière de manière très
pas vraiment très très intuitive toute
l'histoire évolutive
[Musique]